good day everyone this is jack van horn
from the university of southern
california and please allow me to
welcome you to the big data to knowledge
guide to the fundamentals of data
science seminar series where today we
have an aunt gramma from purdue
university and mehmet koyu turk from
case western reserve university who will
be discussing their work on the
theoretical foundations of software
infrastructure for biological network
databases um our
one of our two speakers ananth grama is
the samuel conte professor of computer
science at purdue university um where he
has areas of research in the
domain of high performance computing
large-scale data analytics and
computational biology where he has
offered numerous papers and co-authored
a textbook entitled introduction to
parallel computing design and analysis
of algorithms and he received his phd
from the university of minnesota in 1996
and has been at purdue ever since that
time
koyu turk received his phd in 2006 in
computer science from purdue university
and received his bachelor of science in
his master's degree from bill kent
university in electrical engineering and
computer and computer engineering where
he's now a current currently a professor
in the department of electrical
engineering and computer science at case
western reserve university and holds
secondary appointment at the center for
proteomics and bioinformatics at case
western school of medicine his research
focuses on the analysis of biological
networks system biology of complex
diseases and computational genomics
finally he is also an associate editor
for the ieee acm transactions on
computational biology and bioinformatics
we're very excited to have them
discussing their work today and uh as
always i'd like to invite our audience
members to submit any questions that
they have during their presentation
via the go to webinar question
submission system it's located in the
little panel usually over on the right
side of your screen
during the last 10 minutes of the hour
we'll go through or i will go through
those and ask those questions on your
behalf without further ado i'd like to
welcome ananth and mehmet and ask them
to uh uh just tell them to take the
stage the stage is yours gentlemen
thank you jack
this is my medical turk hello everyone
good morning good afternoon or good
evening depending on where you are
so we are happy to
be talking about
uh the
the the effort on building network
databases uh which aims to enable
integrated querying of uh biological
networks in real time
and
i will start by motivating what we mean
by that what we mean by querying
biological networks and what we mean by
biological networks after all
so
if we think about the big data of
biology which people usually call call
or make in the context of the central
dogma of biology
we have access to data on dna we have
access to data on rna in terms of both
the abundance of gene expression
profiles in a
transcription sample
and also rna structure alternative
splicing and so on and then also at the
protein level we can measure protein
expression look at protein structure
and then at the functional level
we can look at protein-protein
interactions post-translational
modification of proteins metabolites and
so on and so forth and this gave rise to
phenomena we can also measure a lot of
things at a very large scale in terms of
the phenotypes like
biomass this is state clinical outcome
and so on so forth so in the context of
precision medicine
one important goal is to be able to
integrate the islamic data to make sense
of human diseases for example
and it's important to note that most of
this data can be represented or
naturally
or naturally comes from
comes in the form of
networks so
and indeed there are lots of biological
network databases out there and these
networks contain different types of
information in terms of the interactions
and associations between biomolecules
but not just by biomolecules
also different entities
that can be thought of
in the context of biological data
analysis so for example protein protein
interactions are one form of network
data where you have information on the
physical binding of different proteins
and this is usually obtained through
high throughput experiments but also
protein interactions can be pretty
predicted uh using computational tools
then protein dna interactions gives an
idea about regulatory a transcriptional
regulation and
and other regulatory interactions uh
small molecule and protein interactions
again give an idea about regulation of
proteins post-translational regulation
of proteins enzyme substrate
interactions spot in the context of
metabolics also in the context of
post-translational modification of
proteins so these are really at the
biological at the cellular level
interactions that can be represented as
networks but going beyond that also
between genes we can talk about
functional or statistical interactions
so for example if two genes
are known to
take part in
in the same process that's a functional
interaction between the genes or
statistical interactions for example if
two genes show up in the same context if
they are expressed together in the same
context
then this is a statistical interaction
and it has value
to be
included in a network contest context in
a network database
and again functional interactions
between genomic elements for example
synthetic lethality you knock out one
gene
in the cell the cell doesn't die you
knock out the other one the cell doesn't
die but when you knock out pork the cell
dies this is the functional interaction
again all these functional interactions
can be represented as networks
finally uh not just this statistical or
physical interactions but also
associations observed and inferred
associations between different
biological entities can also be
represented as networks for example
genotype phenotype associations if one
gene is
identified as being implicated or is
being associated in a particular disease
then that is an interaction or it's an
association between the gene and the
disease and for example the omim
database the online mandarin inheritance
in man database contains this kind of
information and that database can be
thought of as a biological network
database similarly the function
associations among molecules the
evolutionary relationships between genes
can all be represented in the form of
networks
so what you are looking at here
from a paper that was published in 2011
is the list of different types of
is the visualization of different types
of biological networks and the
interactions between them essentially
different types of biological network
databases contain different types of
biological network information they do
interact with each other but the
information that they convey the
information that they are focused on is
different for different databases
and people have done a lot with these
network databases so for example by
constructing this is gene networks uh
researchers are able to transfer
knowledge on genes implicated in
different diseases to prioritize genes
to look at for another disease and you
can do this really by
looking at the clinical similarity
between the diseases looking at the
functional similarity between the genes
and also looking at the associations
between the diseases you can put these
all in a network context and then use
that network context to transfer
information so similarly the con concept
of phenology is based on the
representation of evolutionary
relationships between genes in in the
in the form of a network and then making
inferences on which phenotypes in which
organisms map to each other
so
we have done a lot of work on
identifying tissue-specific networks or
identifying and uncovering the
relationship between genes that are
mutated in cancers versus that are
transcriptionally disregulated in
cancers again using network contexts but
the bottom line is although these
applications have been successful
the researchers who do this kind of
research will always
need to go to each different database as
i said different network databases
contain different types of network
information so they will if if they will
use three types of four types of
different network information they will
need to go to each database download the
data from there in bug and then they
will have to uh
they will have to develop algorithms at
home
uh
in their own labs
to pre-process to integrate and then to
analyze these data so that they can make
inferences one question that we are
exploring in this webinar and and also
in our project that was supported by
this big data initiative is
how far are we from integrated querying
of biological data that is can we do
these tests which have been shown to be
successful again and again can we do
them by just going to the web and
without having to connecting to all
these databases
querying the databases at once in real
time all together for such sophisticated
grading tasks so as you listen to us uh
really i will ask you to
think about this question again and
again because i mean we will describe
several efforts uh toward this end and
of course you know if you are trying to
provide a fast efficient and stable
querying
infrastructure for a network the first
thing that you need to have is a network
database and now i will
pass
the microphone to professor grama and he
will talk about
one of the network databases that the
database systems that we are trying to
develop
thank you moment
all right so
uh the rest of the talk is is organized
as follows i will spend the next few
minutes describing uh the software
aspects of this database what all of its
features and and the
benefits of using this database over any
of the other databases that you might
have encountered
and then we'll talk about some specific
network algorithms and then we'll
conclude with some examples of how you
might use an infrastructure like this
so the motivation here is that you have
interaction data that can have millions
of nodes and edges the networks
themselves are continuously updated
there are many different versions of
these networks uh networks represent
dynamic systems uh so you have to have
some integration molecular data you have
to capture network dynamics and the key
question that you're posed with is can
you build a scalable integrated graph
system
that supports versioning that supports
integrated querying that supports
analytics
all in place without requiring users to
install all of these different tools
so
this effort for us led into the
development of what is called trueno
this is our hybrid graph data store
slash computational engine i'll try to
impress upon you that this this does
have a tremendous set of features uh for
for a diverse set of applications so
this is uh this is a database that's
meant to run in the cloud it is
distributed it's resilient uh and it's a
fast static graph store
when i say static it means that once
you've integrated the data into the
store the data becomes available for
analytics static does here doesn't mean
that you can't update the data you can
it actually supports versioning it
supports dynamic networks uh it supports
distributed computations uh it supports
online queries traversals analytics
it scales to very very large uh network
databases and when i say large i mean
billions of nodes and edges is what we
have tested these two there's literally
like a three mouse click setup uh for
both cluster and single instance uh
installations for these things and it
provides a very powerful friendly and
intuitive interface for network analysis
it's got a library of tools that are
already built into it and it has hooks
for visualization both to other tools
and and a visualization module built
into the database
all right so
many of you might have used other
databases neo4j uh oriented db titan
these are our commonly used databases uh
and truano does a good job of supporting
a number of features that we set out you
know first of all it's a free district
open source distributed version
you can i'll at the end of this talk
there'll be a github repository where
you can download this from uh it's easy
start like i said literally about three
mouse clicks will get you started uh
it's got multi-language connectors you
can program trueno queries and and
applications in a rich class of
languages
it's it's scalable uh in terms of
visualization uh supports gpu based
visualization rendering uh it's got a
rich collection of built-in algorithms
for for analysis and finally it supports
dynamic graphs
all right so it turns out this is a
tremendously sophisticated piece of code
and there's no way any of us would write
something like this from the ground up
so it does leverage a number of existing
systems
at the bottom of it is a storage layer
which is cassandra
this is a key value store that is
actually quite commonly used
in such cloud-based applications uh on
top of it is is a visualization layer
you have hooks to commonly used tools
such as cytoscape and sigma.js
there's a computation layer that gets
your interface into a very common graph
interface called graphics
and and networkx as well and there are
language bindings that are supported as
well
the architecture of trueno uh is is
shown here um
it's it's got uh at the top level it's
got a couple of interfaces it's got an
interface with gremlin and this is a
language for intuitive and easy
interaction with the graph database
it's got a web console which means that
if you didn't want to actually ever code
anything uh there's a nice web-based
interface as well
there's a truano core
this is this is essentially what we
developed which is uh
essentially a the core of how
graphs are organized how graphs are
version how you interface with the the
front end uh and of course at the
underneath trueno core uh we use
everything from elasticsearch which is a
indexing technique for fast search uh we
use spark which is a
a data processing system used for a
distributed graph processing in our case
uh graphics specifically uh and of
course at the bottom of all of this is
is cassandra which is a scalable high
availability column store uh database
all right so the storage schema here is
is as follows each key space is is a
graph
we have distributed work workload and
storage uh you can choose to replicate
your your data for increased
availability and this is something a
user can control uh data is in fact
sharded which means that it is actually
broken in little pieces
across uh different uh nodes in the
cloud and this is to make sure that you
have horizontal scaling in other words
that if you want more throughput uh
sharding gives you more throughput by
relying on more nodes uh to get you the
data uh it supports multiple properties
on edges and vertices uh so for example
if you if your interactions have
properties you can put them on edges uh
word c's themselves uh these may be
expression profiles that that you can
store on on vertices uh and finally
analytics results are stored in graph
structure as well for easy uh post
processing and
analysis
i'm going to go through this a little
quickly as mehmet already mentioned this
uh you know the way people normally work
now you go to a database you download uh
your your data you write uh analytics
and c plus plus or java python typically
link to a graph library see your results
and go from there and what we're looking
to do really is to integrate all of that
into a store so that you can you can
significantly accelerate and make easy
the process of compute visualize and
analyze your results
this is a typical
execution flow for for what happens
inside rueno
you get a query you know this could be
something
along the lines of g dot v which will
simply give you all the vertices in the
graph g or g dot e which will give you
all the edges in in the graph uh the
gremlin server pulls all the data from
the back end at this point you might
choose to just visualize it uh or you
can look at one of the other key
features here uh all of these things are
scheduled the analytics tasks are
scheduled completely transparent to you
on all of the the cloud resources
resources that are available
and there's a rich set of functionality
that goes with this thing as well
the language connectors that you have
available you can program this thing in
python node.js javascript java what have
you use
scala so it's a very rich set of
languages that are supported which all
get transparently executed on this graph
database
the installation is easy like i said uh
a few mouse clicks will install this
thing for you uh the data import uh uses
an import tool to load graphs from json
formatted files this is not
sophisticated it can be very easily done
uh the compute server allows execution
of algorithms in a graph within a few
clicks
there are examples in in the github page
where we show that you know very
commonly used tools can can be
instantiated within a very small number
of clicks as well um
it relies on a very fast graph analytic
a visualization user interface which
lets you interactively explore the graph
as well in addition to any analytics
queries that you might choose to write
so this is an example of what a query
might look like uh so like i said feel
free to go to the github repository
there's a complete documentation of this
tool as well
we're fairly far along in all of this
implementation the core is mostly
implemented the web console is mostly
implemented uh
what we're we're working on right now
are things like dynamic graphs and and
and version graphs uh but there's a core
functionality that you can easily use at
this point in the version that is
available to you
uh the performance we benchmarked this
performance against neo4j for those of
you who use these things
neo4j is probably the state-of-the-art
it's a fairly expensive piece of
software too uh so this is about a 1.2
to 1.5 times faster on larger data sets
uh the reads and writes 90 10 read write
mix behave similar to neo4j uh it's
significantly faster than neo4j on on
single right performance
uh the compute engine itself is
significantly faster for example trueno
is about twice as fast as neo4j on on
things like pagerank fairly simple
benchmarks uh that we run on these
things so the bottom line is you can
choose to use neo4j pay a lot of money
but you probably for most of the things
that we choose to do do not get the same
performance as true enough
finally we show that this is very
elastic
if your throughput go throughput
requirements go up uh this is very
scalable you can increase the number of
executors uh and you get you can get
fairly good scaling on throughput as you
go through so this uh brings us to the
end of the infrastructure part i will
hand it off to memit now who can talk
about algorithms and we'll come back and
talk of of use cases and applications
thank you anand
okay so
i mean anant has already mentioned for
example benchmarking at reno
uh
for the page rank algorithm so one
question you may have is why do we care
about maintenance right in the context
of biological network analysis so i will
dive into that a little i will i will
try to
motivate a specific type of query that
you can run on these network databases
what we call network proximity queries i
will try to motivate it and also
especially for the computational
audience i will i will try to show
a few examples of how interesting
computational problems can arise from
this and how we solve from these
problems and then we will go into
applications of this uh so network
proximity queries are essentially you
know based on the motivation that say we
have a set of nodes in these networks
and these nodes can be proteins that are
identified in an experiment right you
compared a particular experimental
condition to another to a control
whatever and you identified some
proteins as being
significantly differentially expressed
significantly differentially
phosphorylated
so what you want to do is you want to
ask the question what is the function
relationship between them why do they
show up together in an experiment
and then second can we also identify
other nodes again in these networks that
are function relevant because
i want to
uh i want to be able to
functionally notate my finding right so
of course this is not limited to just
proteins that are identified in an
experiment but for example if you have
variants that you identify as being
associated with a disease again the same
question is there right what is the
functional connection between
and then if i already know some variants
that are experimentally validated i want
to be able to use them to
rank other candidates that i might i may
have so
these types of questions are endless in
the context of biological exploration
right
the notes as i said are not just limited
to molecules
or genomic variants but any biological
entity like a function
like a pathway like a disease like a
species like an organism uh can be
thought of as nodes in these networks
so for example
then the network proximity querying
tries to answer this question of what is
the functional connection between them
or how can we identify uh
additional nodes that are function
related to these query nodes is when you
map these nodes of interest to the
network uh in here for example
here on b what you are seeing is a
clustered
group of nodes if the
query nodes are shown in black here then
we could infer that the white nodes
around them are also probably function
related to the experiment that we have
to the context that we have so they have
a good chance of being considered also
but
if for example the query nodes are quite
dispersed around the network which you
would expect to happen in random
situations uh then you can you
then you know you will probably have to
do additional searches to see what's
going on here and why these proteins or
why these nodes are not uh
are dispersed across the network and
there could be different explanations
too
so
then the question is how do we really
quantify the connectedness or the
closeness or the proximity between
different nodes in a network so
to motivate information flow based
algorithms and these algorithms have
been used tremendously in the last five
ten years in the context of network
analysis
so i have this simple example so here
what i am showing is
three hypothetical
uh pairs of nodes says s1 and t1 s2 and
t2 and s3 and t3 so when i ask you the
question of
which one which is t pair is most likely
to be associated with each other just
based on this network topology
i believe many will disqualify s3 and t3
because a4 the the node that connects
them seems to be quite
well connected so
their
indirect connection through a4 can be
arbitrary and may not mean much
but for example if you look at s22 there
are multiple paths connecting them so
the
uh the the network topologies suggest
that actually they may be talking they
may be related to each other and at the
absence of dynamic information on
biological networks really the models
that we have for these networks are
quite quite crude in the sense that
really all we know is either whether
they bind to each other physically or
they are functionally associated and so
on and so forth
a useful measure of
network proximity
comes in the form of information flow
based models and there are lots of
information flow-based algorithms to
assess network proximity so these
include for example effective resistance
random work with restarts network
propagation network diffusion diffusion
state distance and etc
and as i said you know this has been
used a lot in the context of biology but
always almost always
uh by downloading data in bulk and then
writing developing your own code and
then analyzing your data
in your
own servers instead of running queries
on these
and of course this has also found the
applications
in other domains like link prediction
recommender systems and of course web
creating and that's where the
name google page rank the name page bank
comes from
so so one of the information flow based
algorithms that is popular is random
work with restarts and mathematical
formulation is out there but the the
general idea is this so what you do is
you have the network and you have
one or more query nodes let's assume
that you have one query node for
simplicity but you really usually
in the context of biological
applications usually you have multiple
query nodes because again the query
nodes that you are interested in are
usually
uh
the the purpose of the query is really
try understand the function from
connection between your query nodes but
for example let's assume that we have
one query and the the mathematical model
for random works is
uh to stimulate a random vocab on the
network such that you start from the
node of interest okay from the query
node and then you make a random move to
its neighbors to one of its neighbors
and you keep going until a certain point
after that point you come back you jump
back
to your origin
and
keep doing random walk
often jumping back to the query node so
if you let this uh go until infinity if
you if you go
let this go forever this will go forever
then the proximity of each node in the
network to your query node is defined as
the probability of the worker being in
that node
at infinity
so
you can use an algebraic framework to
represent this model essentially you can
represent this as a
system of linear equations where you
have a matrix that represents the
network and then
and then essentially the proximity
vector that you are looking for is the
xq here
and rq is your query vector
and of course it is difficult to compute
this directly so usually people compute
this iteratively
you start at some point you start with a
yes and then you keep updating your
guess and eventually
you converge to the stationary
distribution which gives you the
proximity of each of your nodes
to your query node
so
this has been used in the context of
decision prioritization for example
decision prioritization is a problem
where it it came from genomic linkage
analysis
where you know you have you do
your linkage analysis and
on a limited set of samples so
the
part of the genomic region that you
identify as being associated with the
disease of interest is usually quite
large and it can contain hundreds of
genes so one question is how do you rank
these genes according to their potential
functional relevance to the disease and
as early as 2007 algorithms that use
networking for information have been
developed for this purpose
so the idea in network information is
for example if you have a set of
candidate proteins
that are that have coding genes in the
region that you identify as being
associated with the disease then you
just go ahead and identify their
interacting neighbors and then you look
at what types of diseases their
neighbors are implied in and based on
that you score each of them
based on the
diseases that are associated with the
neighbors of each candidate and the
candidate that is associated with most
similar diseases uh has good potential
to be associated with cure disease so
again these were developed as early as
2007 and the
first algorithms that have been
developed first methods that have been
developed in this context have been
really have treated the networks as a
bag of interactions rather than
including the network context they would
just look at immediate neighbors
but then came
algorithms that recognized the need for
looking at network context and
again based on the motivation that
multiple paths between different nodes
in a network might be indicative of
their
functional association
information flow based algorithms that
you use for example random work with
restarts or network propagation have
been developed for this particular
problem so you have a set of candidates
that are potentially associated with a
disease how do you rank them in terms of
their functional potential function
association with the disease so
your query genes here become the genes
that are
already known to be implicated
in a disease that is similar to your
disease and then based on that you rank
your candidates according to the random
vault-based proximity uh to to the query
genes
so but information flow based algorithms
have an important problem and
i think you know i wanted to share this
in this
particular webinar because
i think it's always important to
be aware of this issue so
either for biological or just
for experimental uh or even just you
know human
related reasons
uh in biological networks some of the
nodes will be very well connected okay
so this might be a you know
biological a protein with a
very general biological function or this
might be a protein that is well studied
just because it is interesting
but you know some proteins have a very
high degree but many of them have very
low degree
so if you do this decision
prioritization and if you use an
information flow based algorithm to do
the ranking what you are seeing here is
that
the algorithms the information flow
based algorithms will do great if your
node is very well connected
but
if your node is not well connected
either because it is not well studied or
just because it has a very specific
function really your algorithm will
never discover it
so we developed algorithms through the
audit this issue and the algorithms that
we do a lot
essentially
assess
network similarity i would say the
topological similarity between two nodes
not in terms of network proximity but in
terms of the similarity of their network
profiles so for example here if you look
at this hypothetical example
in this network although nodes 10 and 12
are not very close to each other
their
proximity profiles in terms of their
proximity to other nodes are very
similar so this may implicate that they
may
have a function relationship but for
example the node that is labeled 12 and
the node that is labeled three
uh
are quite far from each other and you
can also see this by looking at again
the layer profile in terms of their
proximity to other nodes so we have
shown that this works nicely this
improves uh
uh
this is gym prioritization candidate
this is gem prioritization quite a bit
uh over information flow based
algorithms and it also discovers things
that other algorithms cannot discover
because they are always overlooked
but the catch here is really this is
even more expensive because to be able
to do that you have to
you have to generate these topological
profiles these proximity profiles for
all nodes and it's pretty expensive
computationally
but
as you can see really if you take into
account this uh this degree by s then
you can develop algorithms that are not
affected by the bias that much
so but to avoid computing all these
proximity profiles the network proximity
profiles what can you do
well one thing that you can do is
acknowledge the fact that these are huge
networks right there are thousands of
proteins uh tens of thousands of
biological functions many organisms if
you connect your networks then this will
give you probably nodes uh networks with
hundreds of thousands of nodes maybe
millions of edges and on so forth so
these are huge so
and
probably the information for each node
in these networks lies around it's quite
it's close neighborhood so instead of
really computing these proximity vectors
by all what you can do is you can just
try to identify the k
and k being a magic number here it can
be 1500 i don't know depending on your
application depending on the user's
needs who's querying these networks uh
or 10
we can define the problem of is
identifying the top k
most proximate nodes to a query node or
to a set of query nodes
and in the data mining community people
have studied these problems
and the idea usually that is employed is
either use the structural properties of
the networks to avoid doing the entire
computation and just you know quickly
walk around the query nodes and
uh by using the structure against top
immediately after you are sure that you
found the k closest notes or use the
convergence properties of iterative
computation and our understanding of
numerical linear algebra a loss modeling
of the
residual the error that you have at each
iteration and transfer to make a quick
start instead of really going until
convergence stop when you are sure that
you have find you have found the
top k entries in the proximity vector
that you never want to compute
so what we did along this line was used
chebyshev acceleration for this purpose
so the idea here is
essentially in the
context of that iterative computation
what you can do is instead of
using the iterate itself the iterate
that you use for the proximity vector
itself you can use a linear combination
and if you're using linear combination
with chebyshev polynomials you can show
that that linear combination will
converge to your desired proximity
vector more quickly than the iterate
itself
so using this nice result you can also
bound
the error that you make
at each iteration the
essentially
how much you deviate from the actual
solution and use that again to decide
when to stop when you identify the third
k closest neighbors and also although i
said
you know you
need a
linear combination of the
former iterates you can really still do
it without storing all the iterates
without increasing the storage at all so
the idea here you can think of the idea
here is also
remembering in the context of the random
walk on the network what you are doing
is you are remembering where you pass
through instead of just looking at the
future you also look at the past and
remember you look back and remember
where you are coming from so that is
what you are doing by uh also looking at
the previous iterates and again this can
be run quite efficiently and when you
test this on networks with
millions of
nodes
uh what you see is over standard
publiteration uh this type of
acceleration will stop much more quickly
so here the
what you are looking at is on the x-axis
the number of iterations for each data
set
and the y-axis is the is how much you
are away from the actual solution so the
red curve uh converges much more fast
compared to the volume curve so the
consequence of this is
for example
depending on
how many nodes you are trying to
identify either 4 or 8 or
32
of course you know if you are trying to
identify
a larger number of nodes that are closer
to your query then you will have to
iterate more so that's why the
number of iterations goes up as k goes
up but as you can see the red curve
which is acceleration
does it still in much less number of
iterations as compared to other methods
that use either the structure
of the network or or just the basic
properties of the
iterative computation basic numerical
properties of the iterative computation
so this is quite fast and then also you
know there is one
parameter in these computations always
the alpha parameter i think i think i
didn't talk about that when i
first introduced
uh the the concept of random walk with
restarts so the parameter alpha here
controls
how much how local you want to make your
search
so with a larger alpha then you keep
going back to your query node again and
again whereas for smaller alpha you
don't keep going back that much so the
network context becomes more important
and you know the choice of alpha usually
most algorithms are robust to this
choice of alpha but it can still be
important in terms of uh also
the computational efficiency and
accuracy of your results so this
particular algorithm that i am talking
about the chebyshev
acceleration also you know uh depending
on whether your search is local or more
global
the computation the improvement in
computational performance uh will be
will depend on whether your search is
local or global so
again for smaller alpha your search is
more global for larger alpha your search
is more local so for more global search
uh this type of acceleration will be
more useful because for local search the
problem is much easier
so then motivated by this
we have also
developed algorithms to make these even
faster because still if you think about
integrating different types of
biological networks into this network
huge network even after chebyshev has
acceleration
the
time that is required to process these
queries may not be real time still we
may have to wait four minutes
to process a query so thinking about how
we can further accelerate this uh one
idea that we have just implemented and
verified that it works
is
to index
uh some of the solution
so essentially since this is a linear
system what you can do is you can always
take the
inverse of the matrix that is involved
store that matrix and then when a query
comes you can just multiply that inverse
with 2k vector and you are done you have
the solution so it is just one matrix
make the multiplication that you need to
do during query processing but when you
do that i mean the problem with that is
for such a large network the inverse
will be dense computing inverse will be
very difficult it will require a head of
memory and storing that inverse will
take a lot of storage so it's not really
feasible to index it but the key
observation is that these networks are
highly sparse as i said before in these
networks most of the nodes will be very
loosely connected they will have just
one two three neighbors
so what you can do
is you can use graph partitioning
to
divide this network into one dense chunk
and then this very little very little
parts that are loosely connected with
finish maybe that are a little densely
connected between each other but loosely
connected to the network and the matrix
that corresponds to
network if you reorder your
metrics according to the graph
partitioning what you will get is a very
large but very sparse network this is
shown as m11 here
and a very nice but small network that
is shown as m22 here and an m12 and m21
are the connections between these parts
of the network but now what you can do
is you can take the inverse of m11 and
index that and you can solve the part of
the linear system that corresponds to
m22
using the iterative computation that i
described just a few minutes ago and now
you can integrate these solutions at
query time and this turns out to be
really really fast so comparing these
million scale networks again
what we were able to see is if you try
to
index the entire inverse that is the
purple
that's the purple bar that you are
looking at there essentially it will
only work under small networks
we are not even able to get results on
larger networks because because again
it's not scalable
[Music]
but if you
index in such a way that you divide the
network into two parts where one part is
sparse and one large answer parts the
other part is small and dense
then you will increase your intake index
size slightly so compared to for example
the red
method that it uses just the iterative
computation
right so if you are just using iterative
computation all you need to store is the
matrix itself or the network itself so
you are relating a bit on that storage
but
the
improvement in query timeline that you
are getting is two orders of magnitude
faster than the standard iterative
computation so that is very promising in
terms of
uh in terms of really making in real
time integrated querying of biological
networks possible so once these are
integrated into trainer essentially we
will be able to deliver this type of
queries in real time in within seconds
probably
so the first application that i will
talk about and then
i will just you know briefly go through
this and then pass it to another so that
he can talk about even more exciting
applications so one thing that we did in
utilizing these algorithms
in terms of discovering biological
networks
night at night in this to
predicting drop drug response in cancer
cell line so for that purpose we
downloaded data again as you can see we
downloaded the data so we are not still
quite there in terms of querying the
data directly from the databases but we
are getting there so this is a really
encouraging nice experiment uh
showing that we can get there
so we downloaded two types of uh
cell line data sets with drug treatment
with
different
cancer drugs so one of them is the gdsc
one optimist downloads from gds genomics
of drug sensitive cancer is about 700
cell lines and is screened for 140 drugs
and this cancer cell line and slovenia
contains about 500 cell lines that are
screened for 24 drugs and i mean if you
have ever dealt with this problem
this is acquired you will know that you
know from a machine learning perspective
this is a quite difficult problem and
actually there are lots of competitions
trying to make this possible
so then what we did is we
developed a heterogeneous network model
representing
all the information that is in these
databases so the orange nodes show the
drugs the
nodes show the cell lines
the green nodes show the genes and an
edge between a cell line and the gene
shows that the gene is mutated in that
cell line
a purple edge between a cell line and a
drug
shows that
that cell line is sensitive to the drug
and the pink h shows that the
cell line is resistant to the drug and
then the edges the yellowish between the
genes show that those genes are
the coding for proteins that are
functional or physically interacting so
using this heterogeneous network then
can we
predict drug response for cell lines so
the framework for that is
so we separate the networks based on
these
pink edges versus the
dark blue edges
to create sensitivity networks that are
representing sensitivity to drug and
networks that are representing
resistance to drug then we do
these network proximity queries
by representing the drug as the
query node and then we try to identify a
profile the proximity profile for that
drug so the proximity profile if you
will will be essentially
the genes that are mutated
or
that
are
close to the net the close to the
mutated genes
in the cell lines that are either
uh
sensitive to the drug in the is in the
sensitivity network or resistant to the
drug is is in the resistance network
then we look at the similarity between
these profiles and by comparing the
similarity between the resistance
profile versus the sensitivity profile
we predict whether the
whether a given cell line is responsive
to a drug and when we test this on the
gdse data set using the one out cross
validation so the identity one out cross
validation is you are removing one edge
in the network at a time one edge being
an edge between a drug and a cell line
you are removing that and you are trying
to see whether you can predict that edge
so the
y x e x axis c represents the
sensitivity score the y-axis represents
the resistance score and the color code
represents the ic50 video which is the
which represents the
response to drug and that is not used in
the predictions so as you can see the
predicted values can cluster
uh the
drug cell line pairs based on the ic50
videos quite well
so
then we looked at the classification
performance of this
by using the area under the curve as a
performance criterion and we have seen
that
this was quite robust to the parameter
that was involved in the network
proximity computations and actually only
then that parameter became one which
means that
the network was not important at all at
that point only the mutation for
information was used the performance
went down showing that the network
information is quite valuable
and interestingly also when we do the
training on one database and then when
we
do predictions on the other database
with no crosstalk between databases at
all so this is completely honest
validation
where really you are using completely
independent data sets databases with
very different properties still we were
able to
predict drug response
for the cell lines on ccle much much
better
with a very good area under the curve of
86 percent which is pretty good for drug
response prediction again as i said it's
pretty difficult to make predictions
using molecular data
so i will stop at this point and i will
pass it on to an answer that he can talk
about two more exciting applications
because we have 10 minutes left
okay
sorry about this uh microsoft has a way
of starting here at the start
and i couldn't leave my screen at full
screen
so i'll talk about two more examples the
first one it gives you a sense of how
you construct tissue specific and
tractomes
and so the the problem is as follows
i'll quickly summarize this because i do
want to leave some time for questions
so the the setting is is actually quite
commonly encountered where you have a
set of genes
and they're all differentially expressed
the greens are are
differentially expressed and the reds
are not and you're trying to find in
this context what are the pathways that
are significantly implicated in this
context
uh so you know here a represents the
original
you know b c and d all represent
different possible uh alternatives for
what might be the implicated uh
implicated networks uh in this
particular context so if you want to
solve a problem like this
you can actually set up a very simple
optimization problem
what you do is you want to make sure
that you diffuse the the pattern of
dysregulation uh through the network but
you want to make sure that the the
entire network doesn't implicate get
implicated in this this regulation so
you have some kind of regularizer which
is an l1 norm regularizer with suitable
sum21 constraints here and if you solve
this you can actually define something
called activity score so you've taken
your dysregulation you've defined
activities course you can use these
activities course with fairly
conventional computer science techniques
things like price collecting sand or
trees and now you can start to truly
find disease-specific networks i give
you two examples of parkinson's and
alzheimer's
and so what we do is we start from
transcriptomic data we find the
dysregulated genes we irritate
networks with these disregulated genes
and then we use this infrastructure that
i just mentioned to pull out networks
that are very specifically implicated in
in a specific phenotypic context so
these are simple examples but you can
actually do this a much broader study in
this particular case we pulled out
context-specific networks from a number
of diseases
and here we show the p-values of the
compactness of the disease implicated
network so once again here a low p-value
means that you're much more likely to
find disease-implicated genes within
these sub-networks that you pulled out
and each of these cases you will notice
that the method that we have which is
act pro
85
gives you really good p values uh the
total p the the aggregate p value is 3.7
times 10 to the power minus 19 which
tells you that these networks that we're
pulling out are very very specific to
the disease context uh from which we
pulled out the transcriptomic data so
it's a it's it's a really clean example
of how you can use network
build context specific networks i'll
just quickly summarize one more very
recent paper i think this just this will
appear in nature communications in the
next two weeks
and this
applies some similar network techniques
to to single cell data uh and here the
idea is you have a large number of
single cell profiles uh how do you find
a network context or or network
underlying these these single cell uh
transcriptomic profiles uh so here's an
example of something that we pulled off
these were about 80 000 cells so think
of these as 80 000 transcriptomic
profiles
derived from i think about tens of
patients about 20 patients here uh and
these were uh melanoma patients um so in
this particular case after all of the
pre-process post-processing that we do
based on what is called a principal
convex hull analysis you can recast all
of those cells uh in a lower dimensional
space and you see these really neat
clusters that start to pop out so these
are uh for example the nkcd8 t cells
these are the cd4 t cells but really the
cluster you're interested in is the is
the tumor cluster here
and you find some very interesting uh
subclusters within this cluster as well
so the most conventional uh
conventional differentiation that you
see is is based on the expression of
this mid-f gene uh metaphy or meta flow
this is what is clinical practice right
now but we in fact show that there are
other clusters as well uh we pull out
the the networks associated with these
clusters so we pick one of those those
uh archetypes uh we look at all the
transcription factors and and the
dysregulated genes we can find all the
drug targets and we can show very
different survivability uh for all of
these genesis as well
so
this is another example of how
you can use all the way from
transcriptomic data down to networks uh
to really really
target uh precision medicine down to a
cell not just not just an uh individual
uh so to conclude uh network models are
very effective ways of representing
analyzing uh disparate data uh network
topology matters and their massive
computational challenges i think we're
we're at a point where
we have made significant progress we've
made progress in in the software
infrastructure we've made progress in
the methodological space and we've been
able to show some really compelling
applications as well
so a number of wonderful students and
and colleagues worked on this uh our
acknowledgements to the national
institute of health the national cancer
institute and specifically
to the bd2k program thank you very much
thank you gentlemen this was really
really interesting looks like a very
interesting tool i want to
ask any of our audience members to
please uh text in any questions that you
might have uh to kind of kick things off
on a couple of questions in the time
that we have left um i was curious i
didn't quite pick it up and perhaps you
touched on this and i missed it but uh
are the um are the networks uh you have
like adjacency matrices which i presume
are just like ones and zeros can you
have weighted networks as well um can
those networks be directed graphs or are
those uh not possible or add extra
levels of complication
but i can answer as well would you like
to go ahead
uh it's fine for me okay let me try to
answer and you can add so
yes
essentially actually weights are an
important part of these networks because
for example for
the interactions between proteins it's
either your confidence on the existence
of that interaction or the affinity
between the proteins uh usually has to
be taken into account and there have
been several studies that have shown
that if you if you take into account
such confidence or affinity scores
then usually your utilization of the
network will be more effective in terms
of uncovering true biology so those
really matter
in terms of directed networks yes most
of these edges have to be directed
because for example for a regulatory
interaction right if a gene
if a gene acts on the other if a gene
regulates other then you need to be able
to encode that information
so in the database you can easily
account for this but in terms of the
analytics in terms of the algorithms
that are involved or in terms of the
query that you define on this you may
lose that information so the
proximity queries that i have talked
about today can
be made to take into account or ignore
the direction depending on whether you
want to include the information or not
if you want to include direction
then you may be you may need to be more
specific on how you want to incorporate
it because the way that i define network
proximity it was essentially how close
you are in the network
so
when the direction comes into play
it may be more difficult to semantically
define that so
if you would like to add anything to
this
sure and and by the way of the the
software infrastructure the edge and the
node schemas are very rich you can store
arbitrary information on the on both the
edges and the nodes so for example
on the edges you may want to have a time
series these are interactions that
change with time so you can actually put
a complete time series on the edges
in addition to directionality and all
the other
attributes you might want the node
schema itself is arbitrarily rich
you can put time series or any other
information on the node schema as well
so the the software admits all of these
the database completely supports all of
these
i'm glad you brought that up i was going
to ask about whether or not you could um
do things to uh to the edges and make
queries on on the edges and whatnot
yeah
that's interesting one one final
question uh before we we have to go is
it this looks like a really fantastic
tool for training and education and i
was curious if if it's possible and
perhaps perhaps it is to synthetically
break a network to be able to load one
in and maybe with a you know pair of
kind of digital scissors go and like
clip some connections or turn some nodes
off and then watch what happens when
that uh when you've done that and that
can happen in you know as a training
exercise is that something that you've
um pursued
so we
so the basic database does not have this
functionality uh but it's absolutely
some i mean if this is a kernel or an
analytics kernel that people believe is
important it would not take us very long
to code this into the database of course
you could code this yourself but even if
you wanted us to quote it it wouldn't
take very long it would just be a bunch
of graphics queries to remove a few
nodes or remove a few edges to separate
the the the vertex uh the word is the
graph into two you could do this in uh
through the web api
uh that's easily done at this point but
beyond that you would have to code what
it is that you're trying to do with the
two subnetworks uh that you get but your
point is very well taken i think such
experiments really need to be set up the
core infrastructure is there you know we
need to set up these experiments beyond
that
well that that's great well it looks
like we are out of time and i want to
thank
ananth and mehmet for their uh their
presentation this looks like a very
valuable tool and one i'm going to
actually go and take a look at once i
get back to the u.s because i'm abroad
right now but this looks like a great
tool i hope others will do that as well
i want to thank you guys again and i
want to thank all of our audience
members for uh joining uh we expect to
have uh the um
the video of this up and online later
today and in the meantime uh thank you
very much and everyone uh enjoy the rest
of your day or enjoy your weekend thanks
again everybody